let's see who's calling from the 778
area code caller from seven seven eight
go ahead I was wondering if you thought
it was important to get rid of that
super delegate system they had in the
primary for the Democratic for the
Democratic primary you mean yeah yeah
yeah I want to see it go I think it's a
terrible system I just
and after the 2016 election I haven't
seen anybody try to do anything about it
so I was just wondering like what do you
think no no there have been democratic
there have been Democratic working
committees and I know some of the people
that are on it who have been working to
take apart the super delegate system and
I actually am not up to speed on it but
I think they may have had some successes
I don't want to speak out of turn
but I I do remember maybe six months ago
reading about some progress made on
taking power away from super-delegates
if not getting rid of the system
altogether so no I think that there
there have been efforts made to change
that system whether it'll actually
happen is a different question writers
ever hate to see all that just misery
happen again in 2022 that was hard to
watch anything absolutely absolutely and
we're gonna need the last thing
Democrats are going to need in 2020 is
the interference of a bogus super
delegate system it's going to be tough
enough to defeat Donald Trump
yeah quickly I tweeted you this morning
about Johann Harry you had you had him
on your show a couple of months ago he
recently appeared on the centenares
podcast and he was kind of talking about
you know Sam Harris just couldn't
understand why some supporters would
keep supporting him even after you know
they would say I support him because
he's a self-made millionaire and then
everybody you know it was proven that
he's actually not he got you know a
hundred however much millions of dollars
get into him and he just couldn't
understand why people kept supporting
and even though you know things like
that just kept tapping that you know he
wasn't what he was and then Johann Harry
kind of slowly
just trying to explain what he thought
so I just recommended that to you this
morning tweeted to you alright thank you
well I haven't checked out that episode
but I but I will thank you so much for
the call really appreciate it that is
all the time I have today for calls I
apologize I didn't get to more I know
that there are 20 people holding and we
just we just didn't have the time today
but I will take calls again and I really
appreciate everybody who called in